of all of the sensory inputs that make
up the way our brains process and
experience the world none are as
important as vision
it's estimated that site accounts for 80
to 85 percent of learning perception and
cognition leaving hearing to make up 11
smell with 3.5 percent touch with 1.5
percent and taste with just one percent
this might sound like an exaggeration
but just consider the way that sound
travels much more slowly than light we
can often see lightning before we hear
the thunder that accompanies it
our vision gives us access to things
farther away than all other senses too
we might be able to smell things in our
general vicinity but to taste or touch
anything it has to be in direct contact
with our bodies
so for people who don't have the sense
of vision it might be easy to assume
that the perception of the world is
dulled or at least that they have to
navigate the world with far less
information but it turns out the human
brain has the remarkable ability to
adapt
people who are born blind or become
blind early in life often have a more
nuanced sense of hearing and they can
extract more information from sound than
people with sight
and for some people this information
extraction from Sound reaches
extraordinary levels for some people
sound provides the brain with
information in much the same way that
light and vision does in their Mind's
Eye a picture is formed and for certain
other people without sight even if their
eyes can't see their brain is still
watching their brain is watching so much
that they can avoid obstacles in their
path sidestepping zigzagging and dodging
things as if they could see but with no
awareness that they're dodging anything
at all
how is it that their brains can seem to
process visual information without being
able to see how is it that sound can
form pictures in the brain why is human
Vision so much more complex than meets
the eye
[Music]
if we start with the most basic elements
of the eye you'll know that we have a
lens called a cornea on top the whites
of our eyes called the sclera a pupil
through which light enters a colorful
Iris that opens and contracts to change
the amount of light that gets in and a
retina in the back of the eye to absorb
that light
and with vision this light is everything
it's the stimulus input needed for the
brain to see the world around it
light is a form of electromagnetic
radiation and the human eye can perceive
wavelengths between 400 and 700
nanometers a narrow sliver of
frequencies that exist between infrared
and UltraViolet
on the back of the human retina are
different kinds of photoreceptors three
varieties of cone-shaped receptors allow
us to perceive red blue and green light
while rod-shaped receptors help with
vision in low light settings when light
passes through the eye it travels into
the brain via the optic nerve which
heads first to the thalamus and then
onto the primary visual cortex at the
back of the brain finally that processed
information goes to the prefrontal
cortex which combines information
gleaned from our senses with emotions
and memories
but there are a lot of other ways the
brain is involved in creating a
comprehensible picture from the
information our eyes provide to our
brain because even for those of us with
perfect vision what we see is largely an
illusion
consider blinking for example we blink
so frequently that we spend about 10
percent of our waking hours with our
eyes closed yet we rarely have the sense
of our vision being interrupted by those
movements of our eyelids and that's
because the brain is filling in the gaps
or there's the fact that we actually
have enormous blind spots in each of our
eyes obscuring an area the size of four
outstretched fingers and yet we don't
perceive any holes in our vision at all
our brain just fills in the blanks
without us really noticing or there's
the fact that the center of our visual
field the fovea is far more accurate
than our peripheral vision but we still
have a sense of perceiving what's on
either side of us once again thanks to
the brain we get the sense that our eyes
are able to see more accurately than
they actually do
our brains are constantly creating
pictures of things that we can't
actually see with our eyes and for some
people without sight their brains do
much more creating entire maps of their
surroundings with no visual input at all
when echolocation was first invented as
a scientific term in 1944 it was used to
describe the way bats navigate their
environment and it was thought that
surely this was a skill reserved for
these creatures who fly and hunt in the
dark it was thought that blind members
of our species had to rely on touch to
get around
but as far back as 1749 French
philosopher Dennis didero noticed
something interesting he described a
blind acquaintance who was capable of
locating objects and obstacles and
estimating their distance
at the time didero thought it had
something to do with feeling the
presence of the objects on their face
due to pressure changes however as we
developed more rigorous forms of
scientific testing researchers realized
that if the ears were blocked blind
participants could no longer detect an
obstacle and judge its distance so it
wasn't the tactile Sensations on their
face that they were using but rather
their ears in fact these researchers
noticed that some blind people used
clicks to produce Echoes that they then
used to judge the distance shape and
texture of objects in their surroundings
they weren't simply passively listening
to their environment but actively
echolocating and doing so allowed them
to effectively navigate the world around
them some people with this ability were
managing to explore cities hike play
some sports and even mountain bike
the scientists realized that they had to
completely reconsider what it meant to
be blind
but what is actually happening inside
the brain during echolocation is it
basically just an enhanced sense of
hearing
scientists couldn't be sure until they
started using MRI machines to visualize
the brains of blind people who use this
form of clicking to navigate their
surroundings and they found that what's
happening in the brain is less like
normal listening and much more like what
happens when sighted people use their
eyes to interpret light one experiment
to put five blind people five-sided
people and Five Blind echolocators and
an MRI and then played a series of
recordings of a clicking sound bouncing
off an object at different places in the
room the blind non-eco locators and
cited people's brains lit up in the
auditory processing regions when hearing
The Echoes but for the blind
echolocators it was the visual part of
their brain that lit up in precisely the
same way that happens inside of people
when they looked at their surroundings
in other words these blind echolocators
are able to build visual maps without
ever using their eyes
but this wasn't the case for blind
people who had no experience with
echolocation which ruled out the
hypothesis that blindness alone is
enough to Grant this ability
but that doesn't mean it's an Ability
Beyond their reach other studies on the
effectiveness of click-based training
programs have shown that people can
learn to echolocate over the course of a
10-week training program the vast
majority of participants in these
programs report an increase in Mobility
Independence and well-being
but when people echolocate it's not like
they can see again it's been described
more like an acoustic flashlight turning
on and off with every flash or every
Echo objects come more into Clarity and
focus with their three-dimensional
geometry becoming clear
everything from the position Dimensions
density and texture are picked up and
envisioned in the brain
but what happens when the visual cortex
in the brain is damaged the eyes might
remain unharmed but wouldn't they be
rendered mostly useless thanks again to
the brain's remarkable ability to adapt
this is not always the case
in the aftermath of World War One a huge
number of young men were suffering from
severe injuries including many to the
Head
doctors saw a number of patients with
damage to their primary visual cortex
who suffered partial or full blindness
as a result
even though their eyes were unharmed
their brains couldn't process visual
information except in some cases they
still seemed to be able to do so some
patients could still move their eyes
towards stimuli like movement or light
even though they consciously couldn't
see it some could even Flinch when
something moved towards them quickly but
if you ask them about it they would say
they didn't see anything at all
this strange ability came to be termed
blindsight it has proved a fascinating
and complicated source of inquiry for
decades one patient who couldn't see
anything left of his nose was still able
to guess whether lines on a paper were
horizontal or vertical and was cracked
more than 80 percent of the time a far
higher proportion than random chance
another patient who was fully blind due
to damage to the primary visual cortex
was told to walk down an empty hallway
except it wasn't empty as doctors filled
it with obstacles the patient avoided
all the obstacles and completed the walk
but at the end still thought that it had
been empty
it seems to come down to the difference
between our conscious perception of
vision versus our unconscious perception
when the visual cortex is damaged it's
the visual experience that is lost
how can we explain this
some researchers say blindsight is not
true blindness because there might be
parts of the visual cortex that are
still functioning and providing just
enough degraded visual information for
the research participants to test well
in experiments but others have suggested
it works because the primary visual
cortex is only one component of how our
brain processes visual stimuli there are
other quieter regions of the brain
processing information in an unconscious
way
scientists think that the thalamus is
involved in this and a region called the
human middle temporal complex or HMT
plus MRI scans of patients with
blindsight showed an increased
sensitivity to speed and motion in the
HMT plus region which wasn't apparent in
those without blindsight
and Recent research also suggests that
there's an independent pathway in our
brains that goes from the eyes to the
thalamus straight to the amygdala the
brain region responsible for processing
emotional information
this pathway completely bypasses the
visual cortex it's a neural shortcut so
to speak and scientists think it might
have evolved to allow for Rapid threat
detection that is separate from and
faster than what we consciously perceive
but there's a lot we don't understand
about the brain yet and there are many
other examples of the brain compensating
for vision loss in unusual ways
take another Vision related case called
The Charles Bonnet syndrome which is
extremely common in people who are
rapidly and progressively losing their
vision due to things like macular
degeneration
about half of people with this kind of
vision loss will experience
hallucinations of All Sorts some might
just see shapes and lines others will
see past memories people buildings
Landscapes or places
and doctors don't understand what the
underlying mechanism is apart from being
related to the loss of vision in most
cases the hallucinations resolve within
a year to 18 months but it definitely
makes you wonder what the brain is
getting up to
despite the incredible plasticity of the
brain when it comes to vision loss there
are still plenty of efforts being made
to better understand and reverse it
scientists have turned to everything
from gene therapy like crispr to bionic
eye implants that could provide a
limited amount of vision to those who
have lost all sight
other medical experts are investigating
electronic devices that could stimulate
the remaining nerve cells in the visual
cortex to allow patients to see one test
of a microelectrode implant on a blind
woman allowed her to identify lines
shapes and simple letters
we might someday get to the point where
blindness can be altogether reversed but
maybe for those who have access to
training in echolocation there won't be
as much of a need
the human brain is the most complex form
of matter in the universe made up of a
hundred billion neurons the number of
possible permutations and combinations
of brain activity exceeds the number of
atoms in the universe there is no wonder
that it's constantly surprising us with
its capabilities and for those of us who
consider ourselves to even have just an
average brain in the right circumstances
we too are capable of more than we
realize I personally get overwhelmed
trying to learn certain science and math
topics and used to give up thinking it
was all just too hard for me but
recently I've been using brilliant.org
which provides exactly the right
environment for me to learn things I
thought were Out Of Reach I've always
struggled with lectures and textbooks
but brilliant is an Interactive Learning
environment where lessons are structured
around things that feel more like games
and puzzles than like college coursework
there are levers slides and buttons so
you can test theories and visualize
high-level Math and Science Concepts
lately I've been digging into the
statistics fundamentals course when
writing these scripts and in life in
general so many reports are slinging
stats around about the environment about
politics about anything and everything
but data can be deceiving and it's so
important to be able to parse it and
discern truth from fiction I took a
stats class in college but it was at 8am
on Fridays and to be honest with you I
don't remember a lot but the statistics
fundamentals course on brilliant has
taken me through the basics that I
needed a refresher on but also has shown
me how to Think Through common cases
where statistics can be deceptive
brilliant helps you feel more competent
and confident as an adult in this
complicated World brilliant has
thousands of lessons like this from
foundational and advanced math to AI
data science neural networks and more
with new lessons added monthly so to
better learn how to confidently navigate
this world of overwhelming numbers and
to try everything brilliant has to offer
free for a full 30 days visit
brilliant.org real science or click on
the link in the description the first
200 people will get 20 off Brilliance
annual premium subscription and every
sign up helps this channel